[Music]
it's being built right now big sections
of wall and we will continue that and
one way or the other it's going to get
built thanks president Trump a wall on
our southern border once again become
the central debate in the Congress are
Republicans ready to rally behind the
president in their last weeks before
yielding power to the Democrats
Congressman Jim Jordan is a Republican
represents the state of Ohio and he
joins us thank congressman thanks very
much for coming on so the president said
he'd be willing to shut down the
government as you well know our
Democrats on the hill united behind him
in this well Republicans think the
president is doing exactly what he said
and that's what we should be focused on
I think when the president said to
Senator Schumer I'll gladly take that
mantle I think what he was saying is
I'll gladly and proudly take the mantle
of doing what we told the voters we were
going to do which is build a border
security wall so yeah the freedom caucus
in particular we took a position last
night Tucker we're gonna support the
president the full five billion for the
border security wall and let's reform
our Asylum laws while we're at it
because that will address the problem
so for frustrated viewers watching home
wondering why the central promise of the
campaign still remains unfulfilled what
was it the Speaker of the House Paul
Ryan who prevented this from happening
for the last two years I think it's I
think it's part our leadership not
pushing hard enough and Paul not pushing
hard enough and I think it also has
Democrats just Democrats are for open
borders Democrats want Obama sighs
they're their party's champion in the
last election
Secretary Clinton what does she run on a
borderless hemisphere so I think that's
it's all part of that but the president
today I think made it pretty darn clear
he's gonna stand firm and focus on doing
what we were elected to do and I always
say we make this job too complicated
that's a pretty basic thing to focus on
don't get too complicated just do what
you were elected to do and we were
certainly elected to build a border
security wall I think that's exactly
right so the CEO of Google came to
Capitol Hill today and you asked I
thought the most interesting question of
the entire hearing about a leaked Google
document that shows a Google employee
bragging about turning a Latino vote out
in 2016 to help Hillary Clinton win so
you asked him about this what did you
think of his answer
he gave an answer I mean he while in
that email from the head of their
multicultural marketing division she
actually says sundar mister pinch I gave
us a shout out so he compliment her
praised her work and then he says I
don't know anything about what she did
and there were two sentences then I
think her Keith Tucker both sentences
she said we were trying to get out the
Latino vote and the key words in both
sentences were in key states that makes
it political they were focused on the
Latino vote in key states which means we
all know this competitive states and he
frankly wouldn't answer the question so
I said well who's right who's wrong did
she say it did you do it
he never got around the answering that
which I think sort of underscores that
this took place and they just don't want
to talk about it so here you have
evidence of the most powerful company in
the world working actively to subvert
our democracy to borrow a phrase you
hear on Capitol Hill a lot in the middle
of a presidential election we're
Democrats upset about that well I mean
that's my concern 3.5 billion searches a
day done on on these platforms most of
those are done on Google and if they are
really having this kind of bias and
their key people are focusing on helping
one party at the expense of the other
that's a problem and never forget we've
seen this not just with Google I know
personally because this summer there
were four Republican members for
conservatives who were Shadowman by
Twitter now think about it in Congress
there are 435 in the house 100 in the
Senate but only four Gates Meadows Nunez
in Jordan gets shadow van and Twitter's
response is oh it was just a glitch in
our algorithm really what did you put in
the algorithm the names Gates Meadows
noonas Jordan I mean so this is the kind
of response we get from these folks with
the power they have 3.5 billion searches
a day all the people who are on Twitter
every day and yet they have this kind of
power and they won't admit the bias
that's plain in front of us when we see
it an email that was leaked from Google
itself so that's a concern that's why we
had the hearing that's why I pushed him
I wish we'd got a little more in the
form of an answer from him so these
companies operate as quote platforms
under an exemption given to them by the
United States Congress under the
Communications Decency Act you're fully
aware of this why not take that away
tomorrow yeah we should there's a couple
bills that we that we should look at and
think about actually taking that away I
know congressman Gohmert has a bill
congressman brad has
bill and both of those bills was when in
essence say you were no longer this
neutral platform when you're making
editorial decisions when you're actually
censoring and limiting certain points of
view you are now a publisher you're now
in fit in effect a newspaper and if
that's the case there's a different set
of laws that govern govern you and you
were no longer immune from any type of
liability so we may have to move in that
direction we may have to look at
breaking these companies up I don't know
what we do know is there's a problem at
least there appears to be a big problem
and we need to highlight that and then
look what is the solution and it may be
just that congressman thank you very
much great to see you tonight you bet
you bet